robbing right Oh know why it was
important to finish the house of cards
series without Kevin Spacey on my part
no there wasn't any hesitation I'll tell
you this though Francis when they bury
me it won't be in my backyard and when
they pay their respects they'll have to
wait in line
eet's he caught up with the actress at
the premiere of the final season where
she opened up about her character Claire
underwood taking over as president of
the United States after Kevin who played
her husband and the former president
Francis Underwood on the show for five
seasons was fired over allegations of
sexual assault in November of last year
which the actor has denied there ever
had any hesitation as an actress to come
and to finish the show out the way you
did on my part no there wasn't any
hesitation we wanted to close out this
show the way it was always intended for
the fans and equally important was we
would have put over 600 people out of a
job so it was only fair to finish with
the security they expected they're all
so wonderful we had such an incredible
family of people on this show we were we
were gifted with that Robin also dished
on what the cast's last day was like on
set it was bittersweet a lot of Tears
and nobody wanted to leave
we hung out in the Oval Office until
about 3:00 a.m. dancing is there any
beverage included oh yeah plenty
you